say that I love my queen my queen
and you allowed the love of your life to
give
by another man what happened I'm like
like feeling traumatic thoughts like
seeing her with another person it's a
lot it's a lot but I think it's
something everybody should do
sickness of the highest order that he
we're on the same bed I was with his
girl he was with my girl are you on the
bed yeah yeah what's wrong with you
he was laying in bed with another man he
was in bed with another man this girl
the main topic involves a banned YouTube
creator that I'm sure you've all heard
of before his name is snico a lot of
people compared him to like a diet
Andrew Tate he recently got banned and
he still does make content elsewhere and
recently he started targeting me because
I made jokes about his friends on the
fresh and fit podcast he then makes a
big rant about me calling me a [__]
saying all kinds of things he doesn't
really make any points he just insults
my appearance a lot and makes very bold
assumptions about me not going outside
and [__] like that which of course has
nothing to do with anything I was saying
nor does it debunk any of my points
Kevin Samuels used to say sign language
shame insult guilt the need to be right
that's what they do like some ladies
will do when you say something they
don't like to hear yeah oh they just do
sign language
and it's funny you're going to mimic
everything interesting you find out
these red pill dudes the moment you say
something they don't like they do the
same thing they start making either file
psychics or they just start insulting
and good stuff because the truth is even
though they claim to be the Arbiters of
logic when you point a little bit of fun
at them when you when you realize
they're hyper most wait no it's not
emotional they're passionate passionate
my bad my bad when women do it it's
because they're crazy we want to do it
it's because they're men not that I was
even really making points I'm just
making jokes about a silly [__] story
and he's taking it as if I just gave a
TED Talk a monogamy because for some
reason he somehow gets lost in like this
winter soldier episode like this
delusional fantasy where he starts
making a like a statement on monogamy
which of course had nothing to do with
the video I made I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna say a name someone texts he's in a
monogamous relationship
this is his girl
so there you go I mean I told you like I
could hear it in your voice the fact
that someone doesn't have to abide by
those rules someone could go and [__] a
lot of [__] that it's so foreign to a
lot of people's ideas because when you
get brainwashed when you get told that
monogamy is the answer what the [__] are
you even talking about what does this
have to do with anything what is
bringing up a picture of me and my
girlfriend have anything to do with
anything that has happened and where is
monogamy even coming from
I just I don't
people are not bringing up other
people's significant others or family in
a debate or a conversation about each
other so weird to me oh to me somebody's
not part of the online world you just
don't involve them it don't matter what
kind of issue I have with anybody
there's never going to be a day in hell
that I'm going to bring up other
people's kids other people's significant
other unless it's a direct form of
hypocrisy to what you're saying online I
would pretty much never do that
so it's just I don't know when I see
people do that I'm just like why
why and then the worst thing is not so
much that you bring in and you're like
okay let's move on the things you're
like uh yeah
like you did something
you thought you said something you said
nothing
so he's always just been kind of a weird
person to me that I don't pay too much
attention to but I couldn't help but
take notice of one of his more recent
viral Clips where he openly defends
getting cucked so I wanted to break this
down like this this was imagine imagine
seeing the girl you love like get
yeah I do I love it yeah I love her I
was about to say I love this [__] I'm
like no I'm gonna say that I love my
queen my queen
the first time as soon as I saw like
three pumps in I just got up and walked
out anyway when you went up there uh you
said something you said something to the
nature of whatever happens happens what
yeah so so we go in there with the
mentality that whatever happens inside
that party just stays at the party like
yeah and so I saw her
I've seen her other men and it's just
like that was seen it yeah I saw like on
like literally right
I want to start from the beginning you
came up uh so it was cool because I want
to get into all that that's fantastic
stuff it's a fantastic stuff what he
really meant was money is a good contest
money
money and
you're not alive this is good content
you already know this is one of his
biggest regrets saying this [__] online
because anytime this man opens his mouth
about anything day to relate they'd be
like [__] and guess what it's true it
just made the past and he dunk like that
dude was dunking on this girl imagine
seeing the girl you love like
her yeah I do I love it yeah I love her
watching this you know what I'm thinking
this is why [__] back in the day had a
diary
this is why you need friends
go tell them not the internet stupid you
know the thing is oh my God
I don't care about the cut thing
I actually don't care because that's
none of my business
it's not but when you claim this [__]
and then you turn around and clown other
people for you you you got this in the
bank and then you kind of you're calling
people's significant other you telling
people what they do in their bedroom
when that's that's that [__] that you do
I don't care how hot you think your girl
is when she got another man semen on her
face she a zero so you can walk around
with that Trophy Wife but that trophy
got stains and they're not coming off
cause they on video and we can plus play
at any point
and you allow the love of your life are
there rule like how big they
did when you're balding that's tough I
use ta he don't know what to do and it's
a bit overwhelming I understand that I
would suggest you to buy the level one
box which comes with all the basics a
daily face wash which gets rid of all
the dirt and Grime on your face then got
it two times per week exfoliating scrub
to get rid of all the dead skin cells
and an AM moisturizer with SPF 20
because we all need to make sure that
our skin is protected from the Sun and
they're going to be able to give you all
the instruction in order for you to have
a good skin care for you to be looking
all Flawless yeah because that's your
money maker that's the first thing that
people see when they see you your face
that's right and you got to take care of
it if you click on the link below you
will not only save 30 off your first box
but you will also receive a gift get it
it's uncomplicated skin care routine for
men that's what I use look at this
flawless that shit's nice compared to
this morning you can do a before and
after
um
that's crazy
he said you have to follow that act
like his girl's a state of comedy stage
and there's a bunch of dudes on the set
tonight Dave Chappelle's big dick just
went on my girl I gotta follow that
so can she enjoy it like what if she's
enjoying it too much that's the thing
like like it's like she's moaning pretty
loud like I don't like
hey yo
I get you trying to be funny to hide the
hurt but that's a l my dude you can
never say another word about any
political commentator being soy this
might be the most cucked out so [__] I'd
have ever seen I yeah listen they must
have popped you full of estrogen the way
you taking that dick that is crazy Hey
listen he might have been [__] your
girl but he also [__] your brain in
your psyche cause you will forever be
hurt by this one she's running loud so
all right so we we want to turn it off
okay hold on we went at two different
occasions the first time crazy the first
time as soon as I saw like three pumps
in I just got up and walked out I'm just
like man I can't do that he said three
four pumps my dudes imagine counting
that [__] I hope you got therapy one a
two and a three and sneaker without so
we're supposed to swap another couple
but I didn't like I wasn't really
[__] with his girl and a lot of
swingers that's not really a gorgeous
party yeah but it's not a swinger if you
don't [__] the other girl
if you stay there and watch yeah I don't
want that girl
it's not you're not swinging nothing
your your girl's being swamped it was an
ugly girl to take
a crazy guy yeah you know you're not
going to [__] yeah
you already missed so much [__]
people call him a cook but personally
I think he's worse cause a cook at least
enjoys it oh yeah that's worse you got
cucked and you hated it this is a place
where she could exercise the open
relationship like if it's gonna happen I
might as well see it supervise it make
sure everything's okay what no you
didn't have to jump today I gotta see
you don't need to be literally in front
of you it was literally like this far
away from me
yeah what's wrong with you
that's really fun you were in the same
what
you was laying in bed with another man
oh [__] listen I actually never watched
this video I'd heard about the story I
never clicked it and you know what you
know the women sometimes joke around
like yo these when they don't like women
they're gay yo you start hearing stuff
like this and it starts to sound a
little true my dude you was in bed with
another man
no he was with another he was in bed
with another man [__] this girl
[Music]
you [__] his girl I I was not so you
just sat there any in style with you
[Music]
you know they're violating this man
crazy he is saying one of the most
traumatic things and [__] is like
he sat there in
India she was on and I was just like not
[__] with it and I saw her and she
was like I was like [__] that I just
left the room
hey
this is this is this is the time to get
the truth from ABBA foggy we have made a
grave mistake you have decided to lay in
bed with another man you have engaged in
homosexuality eh yes the problem was you
are the only gay one in bed because the
other man was sleeping with your woman
you have made the durable mistake of not
only being a gay but also being a [__]
this my friends is a sickness of the
highest order
Nico your visa application has been
denied and then she'll have to like
luckily I thought she was gonna stay
alert why you leave it alone I couldn't
like it was I was literally having PTSD
watching that I was like having war
flash like I just started they could not
do it could not do it they get you out
of your cheating ways what position
missionary legs are like missionaries
yeah you know what's really [__] up I
think we gave him PTSD was not watching
this girl gift it's maintaining his
erection the whole time
so do me and homosexuality it is a
mistake
it's got her like in her eyes like deep
eye contact oh deep eye contact yeah
yeah she's like I want you to [__] me I
was like whoa what whoa whoa what the
toes like this the toes yeah straight up
if the toes ever curl you know these
guys are trying to get every detail to
embarrass him further
I'm like like feeling traumatic thoughts
like seeing her with another person it's
a lot it's a lot but I think it's
something everybody should do just to
test I know you know what you know
I'm not gay I tried sucking everyone's
attractive whoa what do whatever you
want to do but don't drag everyone down
to your level of Filth and degeneracy
I'll pass what about you guys in the
comments y'all want to try it once
this is the point this is this is the
reason you go to parties with the girl
like you got to see if this is the
person that you actually want to be with
this is how you know this goofball
doesn't know anything about
relationships you think the way that you
know you whether you want to be with
your girls you have to take it to a
a bedroom party I think it's Gap
but you think every story these guys
tells cap I a lot of these stories that
they tell is Cap yeah they they tell a
lot of I Ain't That by the time that he
realized
was off about the story he was too deep
I really feel like it is you're coming
approaching it from like how do you not
know it's going to come across like this
how many people self-report on
themselves with drugs telling murder
stories doing all this other stuff and
it turns out to be true we used to say
the same thing about rap songs there's
no way he would have done that he's
probably just saying that for the thing
turns out he actually did have a bunch
of those bodies and why is he turn on
himself because people are stupid people
telling themselves on the internet every
day they go off and they self-expose
themselves and it hurts their business
because why they need social media
attention am I lying you're not but if
you can go through that experience like
with your partner and like you still it
was it feels stronger afterwards like
after all that everything like we
everything was like better to be honest
so you're still chilling I mean you know
what that sounds fun would you still
cheat though less yeah this is a cringe
this is so cringe I don't know the more
you listen to these guys
I knew my relationship was the Real
Deals I took her to a party and then I
watched her get banged by another dude
something's wrong with you bro
something's wrong with a lot of you
people out here that's how you know your
relationship is solid it's by letting
another dude bang your girl okay is that
how you guys want to figure out whether
or not you want to be with your partner
for the rest of your life but let us
know what you guys think hey man I hope
you get therapy bro
how does it feel to be platformed
wow
I wonder if this story is popular at
Rumble I just I just wonder you know
what I'm saying because you're gonna be
reacting on Rumble making a few pennies
off his live streams hey bro I hope we
don't need some good money to you hey
hey Chad if you guys are watching give
him a donation he gonna need it for a
therapy session
I mean it when I say I didn't really
want to talk about today's topic it's
just some medium rare internet beef that
I think is just kind of worthless to go
over but so many people keep bringing it
up to me that I feel I should at least
talk about it to some extent so I'll go
ahead and cannonball into the septic
tank and doggy paddle around for a bit
it involves
you have doggy paddling in a septic tank
of [__]
okay your voice critical appreciator
that's how he talks I personally don't
find the money but you do that stuff I
just like the image there you guys go
I'm sure we got fans who like moist
critical stuff it turns out priest likes
it too I appreciate the image yeah he
does a lot of imagery stuff I I don't
mind I don't when it's properly done I
could see that like a doggy
Bank of his internet [__] I
appreciate it all right